oh thanks to the organizers for the
invitation and and I guess I'll start
with the apology for being the perhaps
the biggest misfit for the program
because I'm not going to talk about
counting so I guess I have it's April
Fool's Day so I guess I fooled the
organizers and but it's hopefully not
too disconnected from some sometime
level from the main theme of the of the
workshop because okay I won't talk about
counting but i'll talk about
optimization but it's related to
complexity not and be with not NP type
complexity because it's we are too far
from there for the types of problems i'm
interested and the classification in
some sense will will show up it would be
nice to classify problems that I'm about
to describe in in two words we will look
at the random instances of constraint
satisfaction problems where you want to
solve some optimization problem so many
such problems exhibit an apparent gap
between a parent gap between what can be
achieved algorithmically and what can be
established by existential results so
there's many examples of such problems
but if you like k set random k said
coloring of a random graph maximum
independent set of a random graph but
you haven't seen any of such problems
before no worries next slide I will
introduce one of the vanilla versions of
this problem and and this sort of the
main main theme is that because the
problems are have random instances
sometimes without finding the optimal
solution you can say what's the optimal
solution you can just do some kind of a
probabilistic analysis and say that the
optimal largest independent set is this
but then you want to find it actually
and that's where the interesting things
begin so what is the source of this
apparent hardness that's that we would
like to understand
perhaps classify that would be nice and
one of the things that seems to be
hinting the progress and sort up for the
grading obstacle it's a certain property
I'll for the lack of a better word
alcohol that the overlap gap property
that or sometimes referred to as
clustering property shattering property
that really originates in the theory of
spin classes in statistical physics but
I will not go you don't need to know
anything about statistical physics for
the purposes of this talk and what I
will do today is I will give an
illustration of this problem for the
so-called maximum sub matrix problem
it's a very simple problem to introduce
and describe but I think what's
interesting about this problem is it's
not a vanilla constraint satisfaction
problem there's no constraints it's of a
different nature it's actually over
continuous variables and so on yet you
see the same phenomena that you see
before in this class of problems
typically on sparsa random graphs okay
so it talked with so for the after about
my third slide I'll focus on this
concrete problem and walk you through
but before I do that let me introduce
one of such problems and arguably the
most this is the most embarrassing
algorithmic problem in the theory of
random graphs so here's the problem it's
actually very old consider an
erdos-renyi random graph with parameters
with n nodes and H probability P so I
hope everybody is familiar with that but
just to remind you or tell you what it
is we have n node graph and every edge
is present with probability P and absol
with probability 1 minus P independently
right so vanilla are there any graph
back going going back to 1960s in this
graph we consider the largest click game
click is something that all of you or
perhaps no it's a fully connected
subgraph you want to find the largest
such thing without counting we just look
at the largest object so you largest
click fully connected graph it's
actually fairly
easy to show that it has this size twice
log in with the base one of a PP is the
probability of an action and this is one
of the simplest applications of the
probabilistic method you just do the
expectation car accounting and you show
non constructively you can show that
that the largest click is that has that
size okay well in what about the
algorithms there is a trivial algorithm
greedy algorithm that finds a clique of
size half of that to be honest college
this algorithm greedy or even calling it
an algorithm is giving it too much
credit because this is the dumbest
algorithm one can imagine it's it works
like this you pick a node you look at
all nodes connected to this node and you
discard everything else then among all
those nodes which are connected to the
starting node you pick any other node
and you look at all the connections to
this node and discard everything else
and then you repeat and then you get
your answer so this is the dumbest
algorithm one can imagine because you're
hardly doing any serious exploration of
your graph you're not looking at the
maximum degree you're not doing semi
definite the realization you're not
doing any of this machinery that you
don't need any of that it's speaking of
doing nothing this is almost worse than
this is doing something stupid yeah that
gives you that yet it gives you gives
you this but the intriguing thing is
that that that no one was able to
improve that and that goes back to a
corpse problem 40 years old now of the
challenge of finding a better algorithm
can you actually can you for example
construct 1 plus epsilon times log in
click and nobody was able to do that
thus far and that's very embarrassing
because the transition from triviality
tuned to 22 to Jeter challenge is
immediate right so there's no middle and
where you can say okay I can at least do
that much but not better than that and
so and incidentally after that lately
there's been a lot of progress on this
version of this problem called a hidden
click problem hidden click problem is
much lady it was proposal in 1990s in
fact it's motivated by this problem so
this is one of the oldest and the most
embarrassing problem in a theory of
random graphs and algorithms still open
still embarrassing ah just just to
illustrate this sort of stability of
that that kind of challenge it's the
same story pretty much in the sparse
random graph so in sparse random graph
all we do is we change the probability P
so instead of P being constant it's of
the order constant divided by n so these
constant every edge is selected with
probability do over n in this case you
can find again existentially large
largest independent set and you can
write down the acid that synthetic lee
what it is it is linear in the number of
nodes of the graph is sparse independent
set is linear and then and you can find
the prefactor asymptotically it's twice
log of the degree of d divided by d DS
here's actually the average degree of
this graph alright so essentially we
know that you can use the same but naive
a greedy algorithm and they will give
you a only half of that and again nobody
was able to improve it okay that's the
and that's a similar and there is a
similar story for many other problems
that I've listed in the first slide now
I want to switch to the problem that I
would like to discuss today but before
let me stop and see do you have any
questions about historical kind of
background here
so here's a problem that would like to
consider today it is the problem finding
the largest is an average sense sub
matrix of a Gaussian matrix the problem
is very simple to state and we have an
n-by-n matrix with iid standard normal
entries why normal almost for historical
reasons because people have looked at
that before so we've decided to look at
it but you can replace it without the
distributions and and studied at your
leisure and and see if similar things
show up do you have a fixed parameter k
I want you to think of case very small
interesting cases where K is constant or
an analog log and up to log n that is
where this but this is where this story
evolves you have a fixed parameter you
have parameter K and you search for the
case by case sub matrices not principle
not contiguous sort of written as
contiguous but it's not really doesn't
need to be contiguous well largest sub
matrix largest in the sense of the
average entry or the sum of entries but
I'll stick with the average for
concreteness so your goal is to it's
your goal is of a say something about
such a largest average entry among some
matrices and hopefully also find it
algorithmically okay is it problem clean
so this paper has been studied but the
relatively recent is not as all this
largest clique problem although one can
sense a certain connection between the
two so fairly recent paper by Bemidji
day and Noble showed that there were
actually the largest average enter that
you can achieve is has this very simple
expression square root for log and / k
the proof is not terribly complicated
complicated they do actually much more
than that but if you just wanted to get
this you essentially use the same tools
for the largest click it's a moment
argument it could be the expected number
of of of something
chris is achieving certain value it's
all Gaussian so tales are easy to handle
and then any show that there is a
concentration around this expectation
and then things are good the asymptotics
here is completely it's not mysterious
let me give you intuition it's written
here but you don't need to follow this
let me just say it in words what this
asymptotics is what it is is that if you
have n iid standard normals we know what
the maximum is it's a standard deviation
2 times 2 squared times square root 2
log n okay so we know what's the largest
of NIAID Gaussian is okay now our matrix
averages on matrices and if we have n
choose K square of them the number of
choices of sub matrices and choose K
square each average for the fixed matrix
is a Gaussian with a variance 1 over K
squared okay now what you do is that
pretend that they're all independent of
course they are not because they overlap
right so they have the correlations but
pretend they're independent and and look
at this asymptotics as if they were
independent and when you do you recover
this so it's basically saying that this
dependence is more is irrelevant it's
the supremum of essentially largest of
that many gaussians with this
distribution but of course you have to
overcome this correlations but you do
that with the moment orchid what about
the algorithms so incidentally quick
side remark is that that problem came up
from applications and in the buying for
matix specifically where where people
have looked at the sort of it go back to
the matrix the matrix actually of
interest is non-square matrix but you
can define it for non-square matrix as
well and in bioinformatics you
interested in ok the rows corresponds to
patients and the columns correspond to
genome expression and then C sub matrix
presumably correspond to areas of
problems for example genes that express
the presence of cancer for those
patients that are part of that group
right so it has applications but I don't
know frankly it much about this
application so
I'll skip that now obviously the the
problem has some algorithmic challenge
to that because the number of choices is
large even if case constant like 10 it's
admittedly polynomial time but end to
the 20 what good is it and in this paper
in the applications paper a very natural
heuristics was proposed called the
iterative search procedure and it's a
very simple in reasonable construction
not construction the algorithm that let
me describe it I I have a formal I have
a slide describing this algorithm
formally but it's not very possible so
let me just do it on the board I think
it would be easier so what you do is the
following so you want to find largest
sub matrix you fixed any of the K rows
for example the first K rows here
without loss of generality and then find
the best matrix within those heroes only
now that's easy to do because all you
need to do is find the largest column
with largest sum of entries at the next
column with the largest sum of entries
and the next column larger sum of
entries again they don't need to be
contiguous but for my drawing ease of
drawing let's pretend they are so you
found the best matrix here and
incidentally there are synthetics of
this restricted largest sub-matrix which
is now trivial to find is is to log n
divided by K versus the global optimum
is to outside outside of the root so
this is global when you do it restricted
version you find here but but that you
don't stop here what you do the next
step is that ok now you restrict within
columns and you find the best sub matrix
within those columns and then you find
the your students within those rows you
find the best sub matrix within this
Rose could overlap with the previous
choices it's actually likely to overlap
and then you keep iterating for example
you do something like this and then you
do something like this and and so on and
so forth that's iterative search
procedure very natural heuristics to try
to do something here
questions okay so what and the in the
paper that established the global
optimality here bye-bye me today & noble
they wanted to say something about the
performance of this algorithm iterative
search procedure and but that's turned
out to be challenging that's not a
obvious to do because now the dependence
is actually mess mess it up things
become complicated so instead they did
something different they given evidence
they given evidence that indeed what you
get in the first iteration is pretty
much the best you can do so this is the
best what they did is they showed the
following notice that you iterate here
and here at some point you stop and when
you stop that matrix is optimal within
the set of rows and within the set of
columns because otherwise you would be
able to improve right so then they said
okay let's look at all such matrices
which are locally optimal though locally
means within rows within columns and the
like fluke and not all such matrices and
what they found is that with high
probability almost all of them have this
value which is square root two smaller
than the global optimum and that gave
sort of that suggested that in fact that
Albert's the performance of this
algorithm
and that's the intuition all right so
some open questions what is indeed the
true performance of this algorithm are
the better algorithms and if if if we
get to the optimality global optimality
you're a great for us but if you stop
short is what's hindering it so what's
what's the obstacle for this apparent
computational complexity Sasha fear that
it converges fast or you just stop it
when you see no big improvement it is
clear that it convergence that whether
it converges fast that's not guaranteed
it can stop eventually yeah did you just
stop when you don't see significant
improvement or right so the answer to
this question depends empirical testing
of the algorithm versus the they
actually analysis as far as the analysis
is concerned I'll give you the full
answer as far as the empirical answers
are concerned is that it's when people
tried it on real data was real by
informatics data they were finding that
it's actually not easy to find something
really good I mean they don't know it's
optimal or not but they start they start
from one per position optimizing and get
somethings it starts somewhere else and
get something else so even the empirical
data suggests that even in empirically
this problem is is hard now you can do
all kinds of trash holding rule that if
I don't improve by more than something
that I stop you can do any ex--you you
want and and that's the sort of user
dependent as far as the performance to
provable performance of this algorithm
that's one of the results and I'll
describe it shortly so the ran it to the
end right in the empirical class I'm not
I'm not sure I don't produce by this
algorithm that
really I mean it literally produced by
the survey may literally produced by
this algorithm until it's get stuck
somewhere global optimality or globally
optimal or somewhere in before yeah yes
I thought people make the understood it
wrong Drake that's all the local Optima
behave more or less the same majority
yes yes doesn't exactly the algorithm
has not stopped good so not technically
because okay what you know is that like
say 99 percent of the local optimum I'll
give this value but maybe this algorithm
is clever enough that somehow it
overcomes that and sort of Wiggles its
way into something higher so that's
that's what you want to rule out all
right so before let me introduce another
algorithm and given that this problem is
so in a way simple is in a way related
to the graph problem let me actually
turn it into the graph problem so the
way we're going to turn it is very
simple threshold increased rational
theta and every time we have an entry
greater than theta will put one and
every time we have entry less than theta
will put zero right so now instead of
Gaussian entries we have 01 entries now
think of this as a change in C matrix of
a bipartite erdos-renyi graph but
bipartite because my original matrix was
not symmetric and therefore this matrix
is not symmetric if you like symmetry
you can start with the original problem
being symmetric you will run into same
issues rest assured but we will start
with non symmetric fine so it's a
bipartite random or the shiny graph the
edge probability is just the probability
that they entry is at least data okay
now what you can do the following okay
we granted we can solve the clique
problem on the others on the addition
any girl but we have a greedy algorithm
that does half of that if you apply this
half elgar it's simple algorithm for
bipartite graph it
give the same performance it's log n
divided by its login essentially with
the right base as opposed to twice log n
but that we can do because greedy
algorithm gives a gift set so we find a
clique of size M for of size M where m
is depends on p but p now is a function
of the threshold we we cannot live with
nem here so what's the implication of
that is that for such a matrix in a
click every entry is at least data so
not like not just the average is Theta
at least a minimum entries of this data
so you know what we're doing better in
some sense but you have to be careful
you have to select theta not too large
so that your clique is of the right size
it has to be K by K otherwise you're not
solving the right problem because we
have a target matrix that we want to
produce and so now you can solve the
reverse engineering problem set date a
large enough so that this is still at
least game and see what it gives you so
I guess I'll keep it as a suspense sort
of it's actually it's it's it's easy to
reverse engineer but but I'll wait wait
for one slide before before I tell you
the answer let me start with a previous
problem so now I introduced to algorithm
one was this iterative search one was
this connection based on the clicks in
random graphs some results first result
is that indeed no surprises in iterative
search procedure will not overcome the
local barrier it will actually produce
the click of that sorry in a matrix of
that size so this local local
computation by bemidji airtel was the
right computation this result is the
technically in the paper is the most
most involved and least interesting in a
way because all we do in the end after
20 pages extremely painful computations
and then so on in the end there's no
surprise what you expect it that's not
you get I think surprising results come
and perhaps nicely the oldest surprises
are actually simple to the
and hopefully some some of the things
you will find surprising okay so fine so
this is this and now I one thing I
forgot them although I didn't forget to
mention it turns out that the number of
operations is actually constant with
high probability so that that's the
sergeant's question you can prove that
with all in fact it's bounded by
geometric the probability that you have
to run you will run more than 10 steps
is Rho to the 10 all right and that's
literally no threshold illiterate you
get stuck no improvement after after
that 10 iterations ah here's the second
except for the second thing you optimize
of a threshold theta and solve the
clique problem and try to get however
large matrix you can get and it gives
you the same answer so it's optimized of
the theta click theta which maximizes
which which the sort of soft right
threshold problem so maximum theta such
that you still get K by K click that
data has the same value a little bit up
shot here is that instead of the average
value you get the minimum value here but
the marginal okay so in light of this
one kind of perhaps time to pause and
think maybe this threshold by drawing an
analogy with clicks in the random grass
maybe this threshold is kind of like
half log log n versus to log and
threshold for greedy algorithms versus
truth in random graphs right so maybe
this may be overcoming the threshold is
as hard as it was 40 years old hard in
for the clicks and random graphs and
that was sort of our belief at that
stage but then surprisingly we found
that in fact there is a better algorithm
and very simple better algorithm we're
not terribly creative in giving it name
so we just call the sequential greedy
algorithm and that's nice and and and at
that algorithm that I'm about to
describe it's very simple and I'll
describe you shortly
in fact the analysis is also simple
gives four thirds better than the
previous two algorithms so now to keep
sort of things in syrup when the
relative sense so I'll put one here and
this one in prep resents to log n log n
over K that's the performance of the
original two algorithms now square root
2 here that's global that's global
optimum that's where you want to get
that's a Holy Grail in a way so this
algorithm gets you four thirds which
incidentally is 1.33 something and throw
two is 1.41 so you could say that okay
it's not too bad we're almost there a
few digits of heart but of course this
relative numbers are in a way
meaningless now let me describe the
algorithm i don't think i have a slide
for that i would like to do that oh yeah
i have a slide for that but to let me do
it on the board the algorithm is
actually very simple what you do is you
pick just one row any of the rows that
you like and la find the largest so this
is the largest entry
just one and then you look at this
column and they find the largest entry
in this column if it happens to be the
same one which is that actually unlikely
actually not that unlike because its
largest of anyways if it's the same then
find the next largest if it's not the
same good so you have two entries now so
if 2 by 1 matrix fix this row and in
these two rows finding next best two
elements so two elements which have the
largest some different from this one so
you have a 2 by 2 matrix now fine and
then now you have two rows find the next
two by two entries in the two columns so
2 by 3 matrix and then now you get the
picture and this fine next best 3 by 3 3
column and keep iterating until you get
to the K by K target size that's the
algorithm and this algorithm is actually
fairly easy to analyze I have a proof
sketch here but let me say in words
what's the idea of the proof you don't
need to follow follow details here the
idea is that every time in step T in
step T you add a row of entries which
are Gaussian and have the extreme
property that so this is a row which has
this largest sum of entries in these T
columns and then you use the extreme
value of the guy ID gaussians and plug
the value and when you do the summation
then becomes like an integral because
now you have extreme value of T by n
gaussians gives you something like this
then you integrate square root and then
you get four thirds because it's an
integral of the square root tea from 1
to K and there is an extra factor here
so that's the details now when you do
this analysis you have to be a little
bit careful because there is a
dependency here but what we do is that
we split the matrices into chunks and
and and then sort of only use for the
best within the chunk and then you
guarantee independence and turns out it
doesn't hurt you too much all right so
so we can do four thirds we so far we
can do one point 41 this is the
interesting region we want to say
something about that so a unless there
are any questions yes when you when you
did your threshold in you know go thats
Sarah one bit well you can if you leave
the value to the entries in distributed
on CETA defenses it must include
unfortunately it doesn't improve because
the value theta is all ready to log n
over K it's concentrated slower or the
magnitude improvement and obviously
quote-unquote obviously you could you
can you can it's about about this
algorithm if you try this algorithm for
the cliq problem hoping to beat log and
threshold you you you fail there's no
improvement there it would be amazing is
it some simple elk rack like this what
would actually get you there but it gets
you gives you something in the Gaussian
case any other questions all right so
what is the okay granted we managed to
improve from one quote unquote of super
from the sort of default algorithms by
four thirds we can do improving simple
hacks like like perhaps doing adding two
columns or three columns at a time want
to don't give you improvement so now let
me switch gears and talk about perhaps
there is indeed some kind of a phase
transition indicating the hardness this
problem and talk about the overlap gap
property that this problem indeed does
exhibit and it intriguingly exhibits it
in the right place somewhere between
here and here okay to summarize global
optimum is given by this expression
best found algorithmically is a little
bit lower something is happening in
between Buddhists to do the to formalize
the phase transition property that I'm
about to describe let's do the following
you pickin parameter alpha between four
thirds in square root 2 so some
parameter here if this is supposed to
this is supposed to indicate the target
value of the matrix you would like to
get so specifically now look at the old
matrices and pick any two matrices c1 c2
with average value equal to alpha times
this default value achievable by the two
first two algorithms okay now we know
such matrices do exist because all the
way up to root 2 they do exist by the
optimality analysis and when alpha is
equal to 1 that these matrices are
achieved by the first two algorithms
when alpha is equal to the third it's
achieved by the new algorithm that our I
just described so we pick alpha in fact
let's pick alpha all the way from 1 2
root 2 I made a mistake we will consider
the whole full range so what do we do
then then we'll do a fairly simple thing
it's it's a little bit of work but it's
not too complicated well look at the
expected number of pairs of matrices
which a achieved that average value and
B they have a prescribed number of
common rose and common columns so we
fixed parameters now two other
parameters y1 and y2 and ask ourselves
what is the expected number of matrices
that have this average value and have y1
k common rose and y2k common columns and
computed and that can be done that's not
to complicate it and the leading term d
is the expected number of such thing is
given by this expression
so its exponent of the scale is scale
again and the pram and and the leading
order term is given by this expression
it involved y 1 y 2 and alpha questions
is it clear but now notice is that when
f this parameter is negative if it so
happens to be negative that expectation
goes to 0 and therefore such matrices
simply do not exist with high
probability it's kind of a moment
argument and if it's positive x
expectation goes to infinity then you
have to use the concentration argument
to show that in fact such matrices do
exist so what I want to do next is the
plot this function and specifically
indicate when it's positive n minus
negative and then we will see we will
see that there's actually two phase
transition one is non interesting I'll
go through that really fast and one is
interesting i'll go to that somewhat
slower there's a first phase transition
is happens at root 3 over root 2 so if
as long as alpha less than this quantity
turns out that all the values of F are
positive so here we fixed alpha and go
over all pairs of y1 and y2 and turns
out that all such values are positive so
the red this indicates how large is the
value and yellow indicates how low is
the valley but they're all positive so
all such pairs are achievable if you go
above this threshold then you have this
white regions these are the regions that
imp represent where the function f is
negative and that means that such
matrices do not exist in particular for
example if you take point point 98.1 it
means that you cannot find two matrices
such that have ninety percent common
rose and ten percent common columns and
achieve the target value right such
things do not exist and that otherwise
the original self looks like this
and that picture continuous out until
1.3 or this numeric value which is
actually explicitly given by this
expression it includes four thirds so
it's somewhere here so alpha critical
now is five thirds over 2 over 3 and
what's happening at five thirds at this
number is that this region becomes
disconnected so you go a little bit
above this region and then you see this
picture you see this picture that there
is a separation between such pairs of
matrices and which what it means is that
when you have two such matrices either
have quote-unquote a lot of common gross
and common columns or not a lot it would
be here or few but there is a region in
between that's not achievable and
somewhat intriguingly this happens above
the threshold we achieved not exactly
but above the threshold but below
strictly below the global optimality so
guided from similar things that we
observed for other constraint
satisfaction problem one would guess
that perhaps this is the region of
hardness these problems this problem is
hard to do in this region um questions
why why do we believe why is it
reasonable to believe that that these
problems are hard in this regime there's
no proof of that we can prove that we
can't prove that the click is hard on
average that would be great to have
something like this at least what we can
do is that we can in when we observed
such separation in sparse random graphs
at least we know that certain classes of
algorithms like local algorithms
appropriately defined there will be a
different talk to discuss that but
certain class of so-called local
algorithms provably cannot overcome this
disconnection connectivity threshold
anytime you have at the overlap get
property the local algorithms cannot
overcome that and that's something you
can do for sparse graphs so in this
couple of papers this was done for the
problem of largest independent set in
sparse random graphs and and also in a
different sequential version motivated
by the questions in of analysis of
certain algorithm proposed by physicist
server propagation this can be done also
for not all equal case at problem so I'm
almost out of time three minutes so I
have some remarks here and and I could
go through that but but let me in lieu
of that and you can okay so you have a
choice either read remarks on on or
listen to me I want to or both if you
can do multitasking I I want to go back
to clicks for a moment clicks in dense
graphs and now in in light of this on
the light of whatever we know for sparse
graphs one can ask in tool again versus
log and question algorithms existential
versus algorithms
what explains this log and threshold
what what what can tell us what phase is
there some phase transition that tells
her that if that at login something
interesting happens we can't prove so
far such a phase transition but I'll
give you a conjecture and that that we
can partially prove and perhaps it can
be fully proven so the conjecture is as
follows so it's I'll describe it
somewhat loosely but hopefully that's
good enough fix em click where m is
certain parameter of the size a little
bit above of the size alpha log n so sir
we did two matrices now we have M clicks
and alpha whether it's alpha less than 1
and alpha bigger than one that's we
wanna see some phase transition and then
what should what what let's do the
following let's fix two to the
impossible intersections of this graph
so fix any subset of indicators for this
clicks and look at the intersection of
this clicks and look at their
cardinality okay that gives you a vector
a vector let me differently perhaps X s
where s is a subset M of such
cardinalities
look at those which are achieved okay so
look at those which are achievable by
clicks and now draw a 2 to the M
dimensional sub set of 2 to the M
dimensional cube where you put a dot
wherever this point is achieved and
wherever this point is not achieved so
some region is achieved here now that
maybe region achievement something like
this so they can conjecture is that that
region is disconnected in this case
and sorry for this reverse and connected
here so the transition from easiness to
hardness the onset of the transition
from easy to heart problems happens
whenever this region of overlaps breaks
down into disconnected components I
think we can prove that it's connected
when la alpha is less than 1 we can
definitely prove it that it's
disconnected when alpha is bigger than 1
over root 2 because in that case it's
disconnected even when m is equal to 2
but presumably and in fact probably you
can improve it by M going to 3 that goes
down so the conjecture is that by taking
em large enough you can take it as close
to one as you can as you want but that
we can do i'll stop here I Oscar de esta
Copa maximum
is it number this average chance of
click Ian Williams average size of click
in GNP I just did yeah I don't know just
this greedy algorithm isn't wouldn't it
somehow produce advantage sighs i see
i'm not sure i think it is very few yeah
i probably I mean yeah you have to do
but but because there's too few of the
larger ones to actually contribute yeah
but then you can do okay you can do the
partition function you can say lambda to
the cardinality but then you can tune
lambda to be any way from 12 to the
largest click so but I don't think it's
going to be described by its just
average very well if you take absolute
largest that is actually typically what
sort of one or two very literally very
few of them
but then you will get into something
like like you would have the separations
the quality of the approximation of the
different algorithms you proposed for
the for the sub matrix because I would
thinking that you can reiterate the
algorithm to obtain better results for
the algorithms that we analyze we know
their performance so we don't need
bounds okay but the question is if for
example you know the expected size maybe
by repeating the algorithm form from
different starting points you can get no
bounce I mean presumably if used to
rerun this let's say iterative search
procedure gazillion times you'll get to
optimality so you have to somehow so you
would have to ask okay suppose I
restarted polynomially many times i am
not sure even the vanilla version was
hard to analyze this would be even
harder but I don't think it will give an
improvement because things are very
concentrated super polynomially
concentrated so even if you restarted
polynomially many times won't give you
anything I expect in expected I
anticipation but we haven't done the
analysis yes
okay thanks again